[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW KAM: Good
afternoon, everybody.
So thank you very much
for coming to this session
today, where we have
the pleasure of having
Tomer Sharon to give us a
presentation on the death
of the research reports.
So as we get started, please
remember to turn off your cell
phones and all buzzing devices.
So for many of you guys here
who already know Tomer well,
welcome back to Google.
For those of you guys who
don't know Tomer well,
he used to be a senior
user experience researcher
here at Google, working on the
fourth floor of this building.
That's when I got to know him.
So Tomer today is
a thought leader
in the field of user
experience design and research,
working as vice president
and head of user experience
at WeWork, which is this
start-up that has thousands
of locations worldwide in which
Tomer leads this team that
designs work and living spaces,
communities, and services
around the world at WeWork.
So there is also a desk
at the back of the room
where copies of the most
recent book written by Tomer
is on sale.
So he's the author of
two books, "Validating
Product Ideas Through Lean User
Research," that is on sale.
Also the author of
a less recent book,
"It's Our Research," which
I've read and enjoyed a lot.
And both books have
so-called actually
helped to increase the adoption
of user experience research
among products teams worldwide.
So this is how we're going
to do today's session.
So first we would have
Tomer up here giving
a presentation for
about 20 minutes,
and then we would transition
to a [? FileChat ?] discussion
format between me and him.
I have some prepared
questions for him
that I hope would be the same
questions that you guys have
for his presentation.
And then after that, we
will open up the session
to Q&A from the audience.
Is that OK?
OK, great.
And then when we
get to audience Q&A,
I would just request
that everybody step up
to the mics on both
sides of the room
so that the questions
that you raise
can be heard by the
rest of the room.
It can also be recorded.
And we'll leave enough time
so that you guys can check out
copies of his books at the
desk later, which comes
with a Google-subsidized price.
OK.
So with that, well,
welcome, Tomer.
[APPLAUSE]
TOMER SHARON: Thank you, Matt.
It's great to be back,
and it's great to see
some familiar faces.
So when I joined WeWork
about close to two years
ago, I asked this question, how
do you decide what to work on?
And the answer to the
question, the answer that I got
is pretty much on our walls
and our people's T-shirts--
do what you love.
What we're trying to do right
from the get-go at WeWork
is try and come
up with something
that helps people understand
that passion, do what you love,
is not necessarily the only
way to decide what to work on.
So we added-- we
created this diagram,
and we added human
needs and ability.
So let me explain.
Passion is do what you love.
You think a product, a
feature, is really cool,
you're really passionate about
doing that, so you just do it.
That's how many companies
decide what to work on.
We also added ability.
Can you even do that, that
thing that you want to do?
And let's say that
passion and ability,
sometimes you see
a lot of companies
decide based on
ability, as well.
And then what we wanted to add
that was completely missing
at WeWork was
considering human needs.
Do people actually need that
thing that you're thinking of?
And it has to be
what you see here.
It has to be a
combination of all three.
Because if it's only a
combination between passion
and need, then it's fantasy.
You can't-- it's a flying car.
You can't really-- you
can't really do it.
If it's a combination
between need and ability,
then it's just work 9:00 to
5:00, there's no passion there.
And forgive me, art
lovers, but if it's
a combination between ability
and passion, then it's art.
It's not really needed, but it's
there, we're doing that anyway.
So this is how we started.
A couple of words about WeWork.
WeWork is a company
on a mission.
This is the company
mission, "To create
a world where people work
to make a life, not just
a living."
These are current WeWork cities.
I think we are in 50 cities
at the moment with over 160
locations, and we're growing.
We're opening about
10-- between 10
and 20 buildings
once every month.
WeWork is selling
its customers--
we call them members--
space, community, and services.
So our spaces are known to
be really, really beautiful,
a really warm environment that
invites people to collaborate.
We have a lot of events that
are going on throughout the day
and over weekends, sometimes.
And we also provide
our members with a lot
of services, a lot
of digital products
to support meaningful
connections
between our members, and also
apps and so on and so forth
to connect them.
Services include health
insurance, if they want,
and probably hundreds of
other different services.
This is my group's mission--
design delightful experiences
for our members through
data-informed human
understanding.
And here's the
challenge with WeWork.
So think about, let's say,
I don't know, Steve Jobs.
He had a relatively easy job.
If he wanted to understand
the user experience of Apple
products, he could have
said, for most of them,
bring me all of Apple's products
to the table in front of me.
I want to touch them,
I want to feel them,
I want to give you feedback.
This guy-- this is our
co-founder and CEO,
Adam Neumann--
he can't do that.
Because our buildings
are everywhere.
We're opening in more and
more faraway locations.
And it's really, really
hard to understand
what is the user
experience, what
is our member's experience?
So from here I jump to
the research that we do.
And here are three
problems that we
see with research in companies.
Happens here, too.
Happens in probably every
company that does research.
So first is bad memory.
We have bad research memory.
Let me know if this
scenario sounds familiar.
Are there researchers here?
I know there are some.
So, researchers, you
don't have to say yes,
but smile if it's true.
You want to do a research
activity, some kind of a study,
and then you-- just
before you start
planning, you're
thinking to yourself,
hmm, maybe somebody else did
it already, so let me ask.
So you send an email to all of
the researchers in your group,
maybe in your
product area, maybe
all researchers at Google.
And then you ask,
did somebody do
research about x, whatever it
is that you're interested in.
And sure enough, by the end
of the day, you get responses.
I remember back in the
day, it could go up
to 10 responses from
people who say, yes, we
worked on something exactly
like that a couple years ago.
You don't get 10
responses from people
who completely forgot they
did it maybe five years ago.
And then you're a nice person,
so you summarize everything
you read.
You send back to everybody--
I see some smiles, so I
know it's true, still true.
And then you decide to
do the study anyway.
Because yours is a
little bit different
and you want to learn something
a little bit different.
So you decide to do that anyway.
So we have bad
research memories.
The second problem is silos.
Researchers are
not the only ones
who are doing
research in a company.
Marketing is doing research.
Product managers, whether
they call it research or not,
they are talking
with a lot of users
all the time, and
so on and so forth.
If you have a call center,
they don't do research,
but sometimes they issue reports
about the top 10 problems
that they're facing, that
people are calling them about.
This is also a silo
where this data is saved.
So a lot of departments
are doing research.
Everybody's happy to share,
but there's no one place
to make sense out
of all of that.
And my pet peeve, reports.
I'm pretty sure, although
I remember some exceptions
here at Google, I'm pretty
sure that there's not
one person on the face
of this earth that
wakes up in the
morning saying, I'm
going to read a report today.
And being a researcher
for many years,
I don't even like to write them.
And I think reports are not
what I call the atomic unit
of a research insight.
Again, researchers
would tell you
that you go into
a research study
and you have a short list of
questions you want to answer.
Those are the
research questions.
And then research is life.
You look at life, and life
looks at you back and say,
I have more answers
than your questions.
So you find out more than
what you intended to find.
And then there's the report.
So you are-- as a researcher,
you have a dilemma.
Should I report answers
to the research questions
that we were interested
in, or should I
report that plus a lot of
other information that I found?
There's no rule about that.
So any researcher does
whatever they think is right.
In any case, reports
are not really atomic.
There's a report that might
include a piece of information
that has nothing to
do with the reason
for running this
specific research study,
and yet it's an
important insight that
might serve people
in the future,
but it's buried in the report.
So I'm aware of these
problems for many years.
And as soon as I joined
WeWork and was asked
to start a group from scratch--
there was not a lot of research
going on there at the time--
I thought this is an
opportunity to maybe solve
all of these problems with this
system that we called Polaris.
So Polaris is a way for--
I call it democratize
the user experience.
I published a Medium post
about that and somebody
responded saying, you're
not really democratizing.
Why do you call it
democratizing user experience?
It's just a research archive.
So, yes, it is a
research archive.
But this research
archive is the output.
Democracy for user
experience is the outcome.
And that's really important.
What's happening with
Polaris is very interesting.
First of all,
Polaris is a system
that gathers all of the research
that is being done at WeWork,
and it gathers that in a
very different atomic unit
than a report.
I'll get to that in a second.
In any case, Polaris
is helping anyone
at WeWork who is
designing anything,
who is building anything,
who is affecting the member
experience, to
prioritize their work--
and I'll give you an example
for that very shortly--
to educate themselves.
I know that teams at
WeWork, as teams here--
and again, researchers would
know what I'm talking about--
are not waiting for anyone.
They're not waiting for a
researcher or for a report
or for a study to end to
decide what to do or to decide
what to work on.
That said, they are happy to
learn and educate themselves
about what they
decided to do already.
So Polaris is a system that
helps educate these teams
about what they're working on.
And lastly, if by
any chance there's
a team who's looking
for a project,
Polaris can help
allocate or assign teams
with different projects.
All right.
When I talked about the atomic
unit of a research insight,
this is it.
We call it a research nugget.
And we just celebrated,
a little while ago,
5,000 nuggets entered to
Polaris, in a chicken nugget
meal.
So what's a nugget?
A nugget is a tagged observation
supported by evidence.
Tagged observation
I'll explain.
Observation.
So observation is something
that we learned during a study.
We saw something, we
understood something,
we understood why it happened.
This is an observation.
So we just type it down--
this is what we found, and
this is what explains it.
Evidence.
There has to be--
there's no nugget--
nothing enters Polaris
without evidence.
It's not about the
opinion of anyone.
There has to be evidence, proof
that the observation is true.
That could be a
short video clip.
Could be 10 seconds.
It could be a minute,
something like that.
It could be a photo.
It could be a
screenshot of an email.
It could be a document.
It could be whatever
it is, whatever media,
but proof and evidence that
what we said in the observation
is actually what happened.
And lastly-- and that's
what makes Polaris useful
and special--
is a series of tags.
The first thing we did when
we designed Polaris was
create a long taxonomy of
tags-- how we tag things,
how we tag nuggets
within that system.
So these could be tags that
are pretty much demographic,
so which city, a
name of the location,
the size of the
company, and so on,
that the person is representing
and so on and so forth.
But there are also tags that
relate to the experience.
So is this observation
a positive one, neutral,
or negative?
Is this-- what is the
magnitude of that?
What is the frequency?
And so on and so forth.
I call them the three
Cs, three things
that people can do in Polaris
when they go into the system.
They can create nuggets.
They can search for different
nuggets under different topics
and create playlists
from these nuggets.
They can-- and this
is how it looks like--
so you see an interview here.
So we just decide on the
clip, what is the length,
and the second that
it starts and ends,
and that would be the evidence,
if that's an interview.
You see-- middle left you see
an empty box for typing down
the observation.
And on the right and bottom
left, you see some of the tags
that we're using.
We tag by journey.
We tag by emotions, objects,
and the experience metrics
that I just described.
And then you can also curate.
You can add and create
nuggets to playlists,
and you can share these
with other people at WeWork.
This is how a
playlist looks like.
You might suspect I
worked here for a while.
So what you see--
obviously the video
is the evidence.
Just below it you
see other members
squatting, blah, blah, blah.
That's the observation.
And some of the tags
on the right-hand side,
on the bottom right-hand side.
And on the right is the playlist
itself, the different nuggets
that compile and
create the playlist.
You can see that you
have nine nuggets there.
It will take you about five
minutes to watch, and so on.
People can consume these
nuggets and playlists.
I compare that to healthy food.
At first, they don't
really like it.
But it's good for
them, so they have to.
And in time, they understand
that this is useful,
and they use it more and more.
We see very interesting
usage scenarios,
tracking what's happening
behind the scenes.
We see people who are--
let's say there's a
designer, interior designer,
that designed a
conference room at WeWork.
So that person is looking for
feedback about the conference
room.
We see people in a building.
We saw somebody in a
building in Chicago watching
all 200 nuggets related to
that building in Chicago,
and so on and so forth.
We've seen teams
making decisions,
roadmap decisions
about their products
based on what they
find in Polaris.
I want to give an
example for that.
So to become a WeWork member,
you usually take a tour.
You take a tour.
You go through the building
you're interested in.
They show you different things.
And then you decide if
you want to join or not.
We also serve coffee at WeWork.
So let's say you are the general
manager of WeWork in Europe.
And you want to see--
you want to get
feedback about tours--
you want to understand
the situation
about tours and coffee.
What's more important?
You search for negative tours
in Amsterdam-- or sorry,
in Europe.
And then you might
get this result,
72 nuggets in the playlist.
And when you search for
coffee negative in Europe,
you get three nuggets.
That alone, without even
watching the playlist,
that alone tells
you that there might
be a bigger challenge there
with tours rather than coffee.
So your focus should
be on understanding
what's happening with tours.
I want to show you
a quick video of how
it looks like and sounds like.
So we also serve beer.
So here's some
feedback about beer.
Whoops.
OK.
So you first-- this is
how you start the search.
You search-- these are,
we call them props.
So beer is a prop.
You select the location.
If you're interested in some
other filters, you apply them.
If not, you move on and you
get the results as a playlist.
You can save it.
I have a very creative
name for this,
very creative description.
And let's listen to
a couple of nuggets.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- I love having it as an
available option when you are
doing crazy [INAUDIBLE]
and you go for a beer.
You sit down and have a
beer and talk crazy stuff.
And that, to me, I think
that's a phenomenal part.
But--
[END PLAYBACK]
TOMER SHARON: Not everybody
likes beer, though.
Or the fact of having
beer in an office.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- And it was noisy.
And then I think
not everybody's 20.
So if I'm having people
come up and, yeah,
it's a cool space
and everything.
But you know, having kids
drink beer and all that crap,
it's fine, but I think
there's a whole 'nother
niche for a little bit more
sophisticated opportunities
for people in that
sector of the business.
- Right.
[END PLAYBACK]
TOMER SHARON: So this is how
it looks like and sounds like.
I obviously picked
audio not to expose
the identity of those people.
You can also watch a list,
a playlist as a list,
not just as videos or photos.
And-- argh.
Of course.
No, no, no.
Sorry about that.
OK.
All right.
And to sum it up, this is
the vision for Polaris.
Because this is not the end.
What Polaris-- before
I show you that--
what Polaris is
doing is tell you--
tell us, WeWork employees,
why things are happening.
Our vision is also to provide
a system that tells us--
that explains what is happening.
So we want to provide
a score for everything
at WeWork, a quantitative score,
and then from that score lead
to a Polaris playlist.
So for example, beer.
Let's say beer is scoring--
worldwide the score
is 44% out of 100.
And you want to understand,
as the person who's
responsible for
beer at WeWork, you
want to understand why
the score is so low.
Then you can get to
Polaris and see a playlist
of people talking about beer.
The way we do that is by
collecting, for example,
satisfaction feedback
through these little devices
that we created,
on the top left,
and we put them everywhere
in the building,
through surveys,
and through an app--
we call this the Yay app--
through an app that our
teams in the buildings
pull out and ask people
to rate different things
that are happening around them.
So this is how
people can understand
both what is happening and then
understand why it's happening.
I couldn't help it, but
if you're interested,
this is another research project
that we completed at WeWork.
We found that a lot of
people don't show up
to tours because they can't find
the entrance to the building.
So this is how we solved it.
So you can read about it there.
And I think we are done.
Yeah, slides.
Blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
Bottom, this deck,
if you're interested.
And second to last, if you
want to start it on your own,
just check it out and
see if this is something
that you can do.
We created an Airtable
template for Polaris,
for designing your own Polaris.
So feel free to use it.
I think that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW KAM: OK, great.
Thank you so much for taking
the time to explain this.
And I was not expecting
to have templates
that we could use to
start putting together
something like this together.
Well, so some questions for you.
So if we have to think about
Polaris and all these processes
from the producers
and false starts,
it seems to me that there's
a bit of this symmetry where
the people who are
trying to put all
these nuggets into the system
are the guys who are putting
in all the hard work so that
the consumers could actually
benefit from this.
So I mean, so in
your experience,
what have been some of the
so-called more successful ways
to actually incentivize more
people in your organization
to create and archive
these nuggets?
TOMER SHARON: So
at this point, I
would say we are kind of
control freaks about what
goes in Polaris.
Outside the UX team,
not a lot of people
can add nuggets to Polaris.
There are exceptions, though.
The exceptions are a team
that asked us specifically
to train them on--
it's actually-- it's
kind of a hidden way
of training teams on how
to do their own research.
They want to add things
to Polaris, and we say,
you know what, let's train
you on how to do research,
you'll do research,
and then we'll also
train you on how to add
nuggets to the system.
And then they do that.
So we've so far trained
two different teams.
Sometimes there's
a person that is
an individual that's interested
personally in doing that.
We train them, as well.
But not everyone has
access to do that.
MATTHEW KAM: OK, great.
That's interesting.
And that actually leads
me to the next question.
Because you were talking
about all these things
about observations
versus evidence.
Well, I mean, what
does it actually
take to train someone to
actually so-called frame
and enter something that
is acceptable as a piece
of evidence?
TOMER SHARON: We have
conversations within the UX
team about many things related
to Polaris, specifically
about that, as well.
It really depends.
If you don't say
anything, some people
would write down an observation
and then choose as evidence
the exact same words that
the person in the interview
is saying, for example.
So we ask them and train them
to kind of add some more context
by extending the time that
they include as evidence.
Sometimes it's not
just a recording.
Sometimes it's a photo.
And support that
with a photo that
better explains or
provides evidence
to what you were just saying.
It's not easy.
We have a lot of conversations
about the quality, what
qualifies as a great
nugget, and so on.
We also have a term,
kind of internal term--
you don't see it in the system--
we call it the golden nugget.
A golden nugget is a
nugget that is so special
that you learn something
really important from it.
It's really actionable.
It's something-- it's
like a headbanger.
It's like, oh, man, we have
to do something about that.
MATTHEW KAM: How many
percent of your nuggets
are golden nuggets?
TOMER SHARON: Very few.
Very, very few.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
So I was wondering,
because yeah, there
is a certain threshold
that a piece of evidence
needs to meet.
So when there are
situations when
there might be employees
who actually disagree
about the evidence
that go into a nugget,
or sometimes the fact that the
evidence might be OK in itself,
but it's not relevant
to the observation--
so how do you guys resolve that?
TOMER SHARON: What I'm going
to say didn't happen yet.
We didn't implement this.
But this is something
that we're working on.
As we train new people on
adding nuggets and evidence
to Polaris, we want to create
different roles of people.
And then if you are kind of a
newbie nuggetizer, we call it,
then somebody will have
to review and approve your
maybe first 100 nuggets.
So there's another eye
that looks at things.
It's not just you.
So we hope to somehow
compensate for things that don't
count as evidence, for example.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
And then, well,
as you mentioned,
the nugget is the most atomic
unit of research findings.
But sometimes
consumers don't really
want to get a finding at
that level of granularity.
They want something like
a higher-level theme
that integrates and synthesizes
many different nuggets.
So do you guys provide any
support for that right now?
TOMER SHARON: Yes.
We also create and
curate playlists.
So these are
UX-curated playlists,
and we share them with teams.
So we can do their work.
We have a way to--
in a way, it's like
a report, but it's
a playlist with maybe a
few more words about it,
some analysis into what
is it that you're seeing
in the playlist and so on.
So we do that.
And sometimes we train
others to do that, as well.
MATTHEW KAM: Yeah.
OK.
So now switching over to
the consumer side of things,
so what have you guys
found to be the types
and characteristics
of research nuggets
that were more
useful to consumers?
TOMER SHARON: So I touched
a little bit earlier.
Sometimes nuggets-- and these
are, it's not the nuggets,
it's the people who enter them--
in an observation, they
just describe what happened.
That's not really useful.
So the person said that
having beer in an office
is not a good idea.
That's not enough as a nugget.
We want to understand why.
Or they held-- let
me maybe describe
something more meaningful.
The members said that
they're taking meetings
in a coffee shop rather than
in our conference rooms.
Interesting.
But still, it's not
a nugget because we
don't understand why.
And if they add the
why-- for example,
they do that because
WeWork is too noisy--
then we have something that
we can do something about.
So this is meaningful.
This is something that hints
that there's a problem there
and we know what the problem is.
And if we search for
noise, and if it's
tagged by noise in
conference rooms,
and if we search for that, for
a list like that in Polaris,
and see, I don't
know, 120 nuggets,
we know we have a
problem there that we
need to do something about.
So these nuggets must be
a unit, an atomic unit.
And it's not an atomic unit
if it doesn't have that why.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
Got it.
So some broader questions now.
Because my understanding
and impression about
Polaris when watching
our presentation
is that there's always
a tension in computing
systems between pull
and push mechanisms.
Polaris seems to be something
that's more pull driven.
TOMER SHARON: Yep.
MATTHEW KAM: And well, what
might be some opportunities
to think about supporting
more push mechanisms?
TOMER SHARON: So currently we
have a manual push mechanism.
We push playlists to people.
We heard you've been working
on ordering beer for WeWork.
Here's a playlist
of people, members
from all over the world,
talking about beer.
That's very manual.
One other thing that's
a feature on our roadmap
is updating you as
somebody who either
showed some kind of
interest in a playlist.
Either you created it or
it was shared with you.
Each time there's
a new nugget that
is being added to the list--
and it's being
added automatically
because of the tags--
you'll get a
notification about that.
And then we hope that this will
encourage people to try it out
more.
MATTHEW KAM: That's
a great idea.
And since you're talking about
tagging, I was wondering,
when you guys were
designing Polaris,
besides the tagging
approach, were there
any other considerations
that you guys considered
for other approaches to
organizing the nuggets?
TOMER SHARON: No, not really.
The only thing we
were not sure of--
it was very clear for us
that this was an investment.
So we wanted to be sure
that this is working
before we make that investment.
So we created that
template that I shared.
We created everything with
Airtable, stored everything
on--
the video recordings on
YouTube, stored audio recordings
on SoundCloud, and
that was our system.
As soon as we saw the
reaction to it, we decided,
OK, this is worthwhile.
And then we invested the
time in changing all of that
to a system that we
can control and access.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
It makes total sense to me.
Well, what are some
of the challenges
to scaling something
like Polaris,
and what are you guys
doing about that?
TOMER SHARON: So I would say
there are two challenges that
are kind of related.
One is that it needs to be
something that people at WeWork
are aware of.
Because if they're
not aware of it,
obviously they're
not going to use it.
And the other challenge
is, once they're aware
and they search for
something, they have to see--
I don't know if you
noticed the dates--
they have to see nuggets
that are relatively new.
Otherwise, they think it's an
old database of information,
and they're not going
to do anything about it.
Although we all
know that sometimes,
even if you found
something a year
or two ago, it doesn't
mean that it's old,
it doesn't mean
that it's not true.
But that's how people treat it.
So our challenge is
to keep it fresh.
And these are big challenges.
Because to keep
it fresh, it means
that more people need to
do research and nuggetize
that more and more.
And that's something that we
don't always have time to do.
And awareness is, again,
always a challenge.
We need to push
and talk about it
and mention it in every meeting.
When somebody asks
us a question,
we shouldn't just
answer, we should say--
and that's what we try and do
and remember ourselves to do--
have you checked out Polaris?
Do you know what Polaris is?
Maybe show them, and then they
start using it on their own.
MATTHEW KAM: Yeah.
I mean, do you guys have--
I mean, at a system
level, do you actually
have a way to designate
certain of those nuggets
as golden nuggets so
that they surface?
TOMER SHARON: It's
just jargon between us.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
Yeah.
So what are some of
the considerations
around personally-identifiable
information?
I mean, I saw that you guys had
to just black out the faces.
TOMER SHARON: That's only
for the presentation.
But that's a challenge.
I mean, we cover the identity
of the person itself.
So the member, the
company name is not--
it's kind of encrypted
throughout a code.
And the same for
the person's name.
We don't even add
it to the system.
That said, if you are-- our
people in the buildings are
called community teams-- if
you're a community manager,
and you see a video of a
member from your building,
you would know them.
Even though you have a thousand
members, you would know them.
So we are always concerned with
people taking it the wrong way,
especially if the
feedback or the nugget
is talking about you,
the community manager.
So we ask the people we talk
with not to mention names.
So just say, so we
say, for example,
if you have feedback about
your community manager,
use that term, my community
manager, don't use a name.
They don't always follow
instructions, but we try.
MATTHEW KAM: What do you guys
do about evidence if they
don't follow instructions?
TOMER SHARON: So it's something
we have to cut and not include.
Because we don't want
people to use it as,
I saw you saying
something bad about me.
Why are you doing that?
That's always a challenge.
But at least the name
and the company name,
they're not included in Polaris.
They can't see that.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
So going, I think,
to more broader
organizational-wide
issues, what do
you see as some of the
necessary conditions that
need to be in place
for organizations
to actually adopt your ideas
around Polaris effectively?
TOMER SHARON: Honestly,
I couldn't care less.
I mean, it's really honestly.
I'll tell you that
when I describe Polaris
to important people at WeWork,
I was asked not to do it,
before we did it.
This is something that I'm
sure all the researchers here
are not foreign to the
problems that I describe.
These are problems
that are happening
for many years in
many companies.
And it was very clear to
us that this is something
that WeWork would benefit from.
So if the company
is doing research,
or is beginning to do
research, it's relevant.
Other considerations, I
think everything is solvable.
We have challenges with
making people aware of it,
but that's something
we need to deal with.
This is what the company needs.
This is the healthy food.
They need it, although
it's not tasty at first.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
Wow.
So do you know of any
other organizations
that have already adopted
your ideas around Polaris?
TOMER SHARON: Since we made
it public, a lot of companies
contacted us.
I don't really know if
they implemented it.
But all of Google's
competitors kept in touch.
I have no idea if they
did something about it.
But there is interest.
I don't really know.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
And are you saying that as
a way to encourage us to try
to adopt some of these ideas?
TOMER SHARON: I'll be honest.
I tried here but didn't
get a lot of traction.
I think what you see here is--
and we talked about it earlier--
you see research archives.
And these research
archives that you
see here are archives that you
can just upload your report
and maybe tagging,
I can't remember.
MATTHEW KAM: Sure.
We have tags.
TOMER SHARON: I think
it's not enough.
It's not atomic enough.
And when you're
tagging, you're thinking
about the entire
study, you're thinking
about the entire report.
The reports are long,
include many things,
many insights, as I
described earlier, and so on.
So I would say, no,
you don't have it.
And maybe it's an opportunity.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
Well, so we have
15 minutes left.
And I just want to make sure
that members of the audience
get to ask any questions
that you guys have.
So we have mics on the
two ends of the room.
Feel free to just step
out and ask a question
so that the rest of the room
can hear your questions.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm in an organization
that loves research reports.
And I'd love to
know a little bit,
besides just developing a
tool, how you weaned people off
of their dependency on reports?
TOMER SHARON: Why do
they love the reports?
I'm sure they
don't love reports.
They love the research.
AUDIENCE: Because it's known.
It's the familiar way that
they're used to digesting--
TOMER SHARON: You're talking
about the researchers
or the consumers of research?
AUDIENCE: Consumers of research,
internal clients of research.
TOMER SHARON: To me, the
biggest insult as a researcher
is when people read a report
and they say, mm, interesting.
I want it to be actionable.
And I think that if
you track and see--
I'm not going to grill you here,
but are they doing anything
with these research reports?
If the answer is no
or not really or not
what you expected,
then I would say
don't listen to what
they say about reports.
Look at their behavior, as you
know, and treat them as users,
treat this as a
design challenge,
and see what you
can do about it.
Polaris is not the
only answer, I'm sure.
It's just one possible answer.
If reports work for them and
you're happy and they're happy,
don't wind them off of that.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Tomer,
for your presentation.
I think it's super interesting.
And of course, as
researcher, I'm
always looking for any tool that
can help us not only capture
feedback, but also communicate
it with my stakeholders.
I noticed one of the
images that you had,
that you have a device,
a physical device in one
of the phone rooms.
TOMER SHARON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So two questions.
One is, how does it work?
How is this
connected to Polaris?
And second, why using
a physical device
instead of sending a
survey to the consumers?
TOMER SHARON: Very,
very, very good question.
So the product that is WeWork
has many, many details,
many, many things
that create it.
We think it's
hundreds of things.
It's the beer and
it's the chairs
and it's the wallpaper
and the events
and the community team
and so many other things.
It doesn't make any sense to ask
about 500 things in a survey.
Nobody would complete it.
That's one reason
we don't solely
use surveys for these
quantitative measurements.
We also know that, especially
for physical things and objects
and spaces, the best
way to collect feedback
is there, in context.
So imagine a conference room.
So you booked a conference room.
Let's say the next time
you book a conference room,
you have a pop-up question
on your screen that asks you,
how was your recent experience
with the conference room you
just used, maybe five days ago?
We have that.
But we learned from members
that, in many cases, first,
they don't remember
how was the experience.
And two, the person
who is booking the room
is not necessarily the
person who is using it.
So the feedback is very biased.
So in context is the best.
Because we know
you're there, we know
you just used the room, give us
your feedback, and that's it.
That said, it's not
connected to Polaris.
This is a different system
that gathers all this data
about scoring different
spaces and other things.
And then you get a score for
different things and locations
and regions and so on.
From there, we take
that and we link
that with a relevant
Polaris, or we would--
that's not connected
yet, that's the vision--
connect that to a Polaris
playlist, as I said.
So if you see the
data about beer
is flowing to and creating
that score in the dashboard
somewhere.
And then that score, you'll
have a link next to it
that will connect you to a
playlist about beer in Polaris.
And these devices are
based on-- we created them.
These are Amazon Dash
buttons, and the casing
is something we designed.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
AUDIENCE: So one of the things
that reports sometimes will do
is give you the background
of the research that happens
and action items that
happen afterwards.
How do you see your
tool taking into account
when significant change
or impact has already come
from the nuggets that exist?
TOMER SHARON: So that's this
democracy I'm talking about.
I'm almost eliminating the
researcher from the equation
here.
I want the person
who is watching--
creating the
playlist, watching it,
and deciding what to do next--
I want them to create
that for themselves.
They decide-- they know
what happened before, they
know about the background.
And they know what they can
learn from what they just saw.
The researcher is
there to help them.
My idea is that
everyone's a researcher.
I want everyone to do that.
Currently, we're kind
of in a transition mode
where researchers
and other UX people
are contributing or
adding nuggets to Polaris.
But as the consumer
of it, let's say--
let's equate it to what's
happening here, a product
manager or an engineering
team or whoever
is deciding something
about a product,
I see them as the
ones that almost
write these for themselves.
It doesn't have
to be in writing,
has to be an understanding
that they have, what they know,
what this can help
them with, what
decisions they can take
based on that, and so on.
That's exactly the
democracy I talked about.
At least when we use Polaris
the way I'm describing it,
those decisions are not in
the hands of researchers
to write and report.
This is in the
hands of consumers,
people who are actually deciding
what to do with the products.
AUDIENCE: One quick follow-up.
I guess how do you
prevent duplicate research
from happening around
or at the same time?
So say if a community
manager in Chicago
goes through some nuggets
on beer and decides to take
action based on those nuggets,
and then a community manager
here does the same thing,
does it duplicate the work?
Or do you think they're just
building on top of each other?
TOMER SHARON: So when it comes
to what we call consumables--
beer, coffee, and so on--
it's not that every building
is deciding-- not always
every building is
deciding what to buy.
It's being centralized, so
it's not really about them.
But if two different
people decide
to improve the
member experience,
that's a good thing.
That didn't happen before,
so that's a good thing.
I don't see that as a problem.
Consistency is not
necessarily a must, always.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I actually have a
similar question.
And just to follow up.
So I'm curious, can those
community managers actually
track that so they're aware of
what's happening and what's--
TOMER SHARON: Track what?
AUDIENCE: The
outcomes or actions
taken based on the nuggets.
TOMER SHARON: Not
in Polaris, no.
AUDIENCE: So you
can't necessarily
see how someone else--
OK.
TOMER SHARON: No.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
that's important, or no?
TOMER SHARON: I think
WeWork has a lot of systems
in place for doing that.
We're not trying-- I
think it's important.
We're not trying to
solve that with Polaris.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
TOMER SHARON: We thought
about adding a feature, which
was there for maybe two
minutes and then we removed it,
of allowing people who use a
certain playlist that indicates
a certain problem to raise their
hand digitally in the system,
as people want to be a part of
a team that solves the problem.
But then we were
afraid that Polaris
is going to become instead
of a research tool,
it's going to be a
project management tool,
so we stopped there.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
TOMER SHARON: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So any evidence
on how this has changed
research reports at WeWork?
Is it dead?
TOMER SHARON: It
changed research reports
because we just
don't write them.
AUDIENCE: So yeah,
I'm curi-- how
has that changed the culture?
TOMER SHARON: For anything
that happens in my group,
we don't write research report.
It's really, really
hard for some people.
But we're overcoming that.
And instead of writing
a research report,
if we really have the urge,
we just create a playlist.
And then if we
want to add things
that we would have
added to our report,
we add it as a feature
request for Polaris,
and we make that happen, if
it's really, really needed.
That makes us-- we ask ourselves
very hard questions sometimes.
What is evidence, for example.
Do we really need-- so
there was one request to add
multiple files as evidence.
Do we really need three photos
that show the same thing
from different angles?
Not always.
Do we need a photo combined
with an audio file?
Maybe.
And so on.
But yeah, for anything
related to my group,
we don't write research reports.
The hardest thing,
by the way, is
when we share that
with executives
that are used to
reading reports,
it's sometimes a
process and education
is involved in communicating
that this is the report.
This playlist,
this is the report.
That's it.
AUDIENCE: Just a
follow-up question.
TOMER SHARON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in terms
of decision making,
how do you prevent product
managers or decision makers
to take what users said,
what the community says
at face value without
further analysis,
or maybe without checking
the golden nuggets you
were mentioning?
TOMER SHARON: So
I'm sure you know
that what users say that is
the solution to their problem
is, in many cases, not the
solution to the problem.
So we UX-ers know
that, so we don't even
include that in the nuggets,
so they won't see that.
It is a process.
This is why we work
with these teams.
It is a process to
teach people and mentor
people on how to make
sense out of a playlist.
And I should say, even for
a very basic usability test,
if you put people in a
room or watch videos,
whatever, who are not
researchers, not UX-ers,
never seen a usability test,
they see videos of people using
their product, after an
hour of watching these,
they will have
enough information
to come up with decisions on
what to change in the product.
And these will be very good
decisions in 99% of the cases.
So I'm not concerned
about that at all.
MATTHEW KAM: OK,
one last question.
AUDIENCE: How do you have
researchers make-- or do
you have researchers
making editorial decisions
about what's worth putting in?
So if you have a study,
three out of five, four out
of five, or one out
of five run into this,
do you pick one
that's representative
and put that in as a
problem and flag it?
Do you put all
three in combined?
What does that look like?
TOMER SHARON: Most of the
nuggets that go into Polaris
are not coming from studies.
They're coming with ongoing
conversations and interviews
we have with members,
mostly with--
we call them graduating
members, with members
who've decided to leave us.
We think not because they're
pissed at us, necessarily.
We think this is
a good time for us
to talk with them
because they understand
what worked well
at WeWork and what
worked not so well at WeWork.
So this is not a study.
This is something
we do all the time.
And it's almost never a one
out of five, two out of five,
three out of five thing.
That comes to play when
you search for nuggets
and create playlists.
So that's the example I gave
with the tours and coffee.
You see three nuggets,
that's your three.
That's it.
That's evidence that the only
three nuggets about bad coffee,
I don't know.
Then probably it's
not a problem.
And it's very rarely that we--
I mean, not rarely-- but we
sometimes do these studies
and then we just don't take it
as one out of five, three out
of five.
We just look at, let's say,
an interview or observation
or whatever it is, and we
just derive these nuggets,
and that's it.
And then they go into
Polaris into the ether,
and then anyone can
search and create
whatever they want with them.
MATTHEW KAM: OK.
Yeah, I just want to end about
three minutes before the hour
so that there's enough
time for interested folks
to check out copies
of his book behind.
So with that, please join me
in thanking Tomer once again
for joining us today.
TOMER SHARON: Thanks, Matt.
Thank you.
MATTHEW KAM: Thanks, Tomer.
[APPLAUSE]